i am not your friend
and if you get greedy and you decide to
come back for more
don't
hey guys pete here today we got another
installment in the series of cryptic
teasers they've been putting out for the
final six episodes of better call saul
those will be airing in just about two
weeks and even though there's not a ton
to talk about here this teaser did make
me think about some of the previous ones
and how that's all connected and what
that means for the rest of the season
also they did make an announcement to
confirm who will be playing the new
mysterious character that bob odenkirk
teased a couple of weeks ago i'll be
talking about all of that and
speculating on the rest of better call
saul's final season and if any of that
sounds like spoilers to you then this is
your chance to leave
the teaser is a static shot of saul's
signature bluetooth earpiece sitting on
the desk of his office in the breaking
bad era the background is blurred but
it's easy to recognize the blue carpet
and this angle from behind his desk that
we've seen so many times the only thing
that happens is that the earpiece lights
up like it would if he were receiving an
incoming call someone is actually
calling saul who may or may not be able
to answer since he doesn't have this
thing in his ear the call coming in and
seeing it sitting on his desk initially
made me think of him leaving it behind
when he left to meet ed to disappear but
his office is way too clean for this to
be happening after the quite a ride
teaser from episode 405. this is similar
to the other teasers we've had after the
mid-season finale in that the imagery is
more about the feeling of things coming
to an end rather than a glimpse of an
upcoming scene that you can expect to
see in one of the episodes what you see
here and the fact that it's in his
office during breaking bad ends up being
less interesting than what you hear in
the voice over in that bob odenkirk says
i am not your friend and if you get
greedy and decide you want to come back
for more don't my immediate reaction to
this was that this is gene talking to
jeff the cab driver with the tone and
sound of his voice it makes the most
sense he's issuing a threat and he's
trying to sound intimidating that
doesn't fit for what's going on in the
immediate story for instance it would be
hard to imagine him talking to lalo this
way gene said he was going to take care
of the jeff's situation himself when we
last saw him and this could be the
resolution of that i saw a lot of people
throwing out the idea that it would be a
huge twist if he were talking to kim the
idea being that something changes to
where he's just done with her when they
part ways i don't believe this makes
sense if you think it through sure it'd
be surprising but jimmy would more
likely be heartbroken than vengeful if
kim did something unforgivable to him i
do think his inability to deal with what
happened to howard will lead to him
becoming the saul from breaking bad and
that kim has to be out of his life for
him to throw himself into it like that
but i don't see him getting to a point
of threatening her and saying we're not
friends at the end of their time
together unless this is a performance or
done for some other reason and we're
just hearing it out of context i don't
see a path to jimmy feeling this way
about kim
i've thought that we hadn't seen any
gene scenes yet because once that starts
they need to follow it through to the
end i do believe he'll resort to his old
ways to take care of his problem with
jeff and then this will be a huge part
of what happens in the last couple of
episodes at the end of the series that
requires that we spend more time in
omaha to see the setup and the payoff
all after we know how things end in the
better call saul timeline this has been
hinted at by gene putting on the saul
style red jacket in the poster and then
again in the suits teaser where you see
the cinnabon uniform hanging there in
that progression of suits he's worn
throughout both series all of this seems
sure to happen but it doesn't seem like
a complete ending either i mean it's
possible that something goes wrong and
that's what ultimately leads to saul's
downfall but that's kind of disconnected
from everything that's happened on both
shows in a way being saul again stepping
back into that role into that persona
has to bring him around to reckon with
his past or make a decision about his
future he obviously looks like he's been
suffering just continuing to be gene
doesn't seem very likely either but one
last scam against jeff seems like
something that would be really fun that
you would do when you want to set up the
conclusion this idea has led me to
wonder if the teaser where we see him
return to albuquerque and tear down the
wanted poster is the actual end of the
series like they just already gave it
away when that came out it was hard to
decide if that was even something that
would happen in the show because it
seems like you wouldn't want to give
away the ending and if he goes back to
albuquerque and there is this huge
reward out for him then that feels like
an ending is near now that we've seen
more than half of this season the more i
think about how much of the jimmy we met
back in season 1 is still in there
during the gene timeline because it's
definitely not on display during
breaking bad there are a few moments
where you could say well i suppose he
seems like jimmy in this scene but on
the surface it looks like that part of
him is dead and gone if he did turn
himself in that would be a way that they
could show that there was something good
still inside there even after all that
time working for walter white and all of
what we've seen happen in the last 6
seasons of better call saul i've been
thinking about that a lot so i'm going
to try to do a whole video about that
soon so now let's move on to the new
character it turns out that 89 year old
legend carol burnett will be appearing
in this final run of episodes the only
thing they've said so far is that she'll
be playing a character named marion
which doesn't ring any bells or give
away anything about what the character
will do two of the more popular theories
were that she might play an older
version of kim's mom or judge papadumian
that saul has mentioned in both series
in this show actors ages are almost
unimportant but kim's mother wouldn't be
anywhere close to carol burnett's real
age in the gene timeline and i think if
you're bringing in someone of this
caliber they almost have to be a brand
new character it's possible but i'd be
surprised if it turned out to be the
case judge papadumian would be funny for
people who are really paying attention
but there would have to be a meaningful
reason to be in her courtroom and i
don't really expect to spend significant
time in court but i guess we'll see how
things develop in episode 8.
before the announcement was made people
thought this character might be a
detective looking into howard's
disappearance or a new antagonist in the
gene timeline since everyone else is
likely dead at that point just as i
don't expect to spend too much time in
court i also don't expect too much time
chasing after howard's killer and if you
need a detective i don't imagine carol
burnett would be your first choice jeff
already seems like an antagonist in the
gene timeline so i hadn't thought much
about that theory either some other ones
i saw after the announcement was that
she could be howard's mother or there is
a mention of someone who has a name that
starts with mar and caldera's book
remember that was all in code and
someone in the real world figured it out
but you can't see everything in this
particular entry i'm not sure how
howard's mother would play a crucial
role in what comes next and the entry in
the bet's book is interesting since it
means that she'd be playing a criminal
but there isn't much there and what is
looks like it says they're locked up in
the current timeline both of these are
interesting ideas but i don't feel too
invested in either of them since we know
we'll be skipping ahead in time it's
hard to say where this character fits in
and what kind of part they'll play in
concluding this story to bring it back
to the teaser if it does come down to
gene talking to jeff after they have
their showdown and if i'm right about
that playing a role and setting up the
conclusion of the story then she could
turn out to be jeff's mother maybe she's
pulling the strings and trying to get
him to go after gene in the first place
or maybe he takes care of her and that's
part of the reason why he's going after
gene and then in the process of taking
him down he figures that out and that
somehow changes the outcome of what he
was going to do i mean if we're going to
speculate wildly then why not the other
thought i had when i first heard of this
was that maybe she's ed's wife or mother
or partner in crime or something and
again this has the added bonus of her
being a criminal which is fun but also
solves the problem of ed not being able
to appear if they need to use his
service since robert forster died in
2019
at the end of the day those are the best
that i could come up with so this is
probably a good place to leave things
let me know in the comments what you
think is going on with this teaser and
who you think carol burnett will be
playing when her character's introduced
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon